need motivation watch a top 10 with
believe nation
hey it's evan carmichael and i make
these videos because you are probably
the most ambitious person in your circle
but you know you're capable of more and
you get that push by surrounding
yourself with the best so today let's
learn from one of the best tom bilyeu
and my take on his top 50 rules for
success
enjoy
i love inspiration and motivation but it
is the neurological equivalent of candy
it's rad it has its place but
everyone because those just happen to be
fleeting neurological states yeah you
you just have to find something that's
way more grounded you need a mission you
need a grand why you need to know what
it is and this is not a discovery it's a
thing you decide i decided now because i
tell it as a story people think oh it
was unavoidable he meets this kid
rashaan and that coupled with all the
people that he worked with requests it's
sort of inevitable that he decides that
he's going to
build impact theory and try to change
culture to give everyone an empowering
mindset yeah well literally a year
before i decided to found impact theory
my mission in life was to end metabolic
disease so it's like you decide and then
you point yourself at something nothing
is ever going to feel right like this is
what i was put on earth to do it won't
feel that way until about a year or two
years after you've been saying that's
what you're going to do that that's what
you're committed to and actually acting
in accordance with it and then you'll be
like yeah this actually is my mission be
transparent
it's a new world order
man when i was coming up you didn't be
transparent
you put a marketing message out you spun
that
like you tried to be as close to the
truth as you could
but you didn't worry about transparency
but these days
consumers expect transparency they want
to know who you are they want to know
what you're doing they want to know what
it means to support you because it's not
enough that your product is good
they want to know that your company
stands for something
but it's also incredibly meaningful to
your employees
you want to keep top quality talent
around for a long time
you want to make sure
that they know what's going on in the
company this is another part of the the
rebuilding process of somebody that
wants to completely transform who they
are um you have to change your identity
so who am i i'm i'm the smart guy and
that's how i thought of myself like i
thought of myself as being smart and
then the life slapped me around and i
realized oh wow i'm really actually not
that smart i just grew up in a small
town and so in my small town i was smart
enough i was still never the smartest
but then i moved to la and all of a
sudden people smarter than me were just
like growing on trees
so i was like wow i really don't feel
smart anymore so that was like a hard
adjustment and so then putting myself
into smaller and smaller rooms was the
solution but
i realized that i had been sort of taken
as a default value intelligence maybe it
was the family i grew up in or the
movies i watched i don't know but i just
had this default that being smart was
the thing everyone should chase
and then i realized oh i can actually
change that not everybody values
themselves for that and so i could swap
that out with something else and
i want people to understand that those
things that are just deeply within you
that seem as if they are innate human
qualities
challenge them all some things you won't
be able to change but some things are
far more malleable than you thought and
a lot of what you value comes down to
what you repeat and so just repeating
myself i'm the learner i'm the learner
i'm the learner it began to be my
identity and then rewarding myself
emotionally when i did that repeating it
rewarding repeating rewarding then it's
like through that repetition cycle
it actually starts to be meaningful that
you're the learner and by the way i was
telling everybody i'm the learner i see
myself as a learner i'm the leader i'm
the learner and because i was telling
people then i really felt the sense of
congruence with wanting to act like the
learner and so when you say you're going
to do something and you do it you earn
self-credibility so now i've got this
loop going i said i was the learner here
i am reading this book here i am being
willing to admit when i'm wrong seeking
out knowledge looking for disconfirming
evidence like i get to feel good about
myself for that iron man
the movie franchise is off the charts
and what is it
at the same time that you have people
occupying wall street you have them
celebrating
one of the richest people on the planet
why
[Music]
because he dresses up like a superhero
and he tries to save the world
people don't mind money
people don't mind that you want to
create a beautiful lifestyle for you and
your family they don't mind people
getting rich
but they care a lot
about how you do it
they care a lot about what you do
with it once you have it nobody likes
scrooge mcduck don't ever leak a photo
of you swimming in your money
i promise it will not go well
but if you have a vision for how your
company can make the world a better
place and you use social media to allow
people to touch and be evangelized by
your brand if you're thinking how can i
make a product or a service that
actually makes the lives better of the
people that work at the company and the
people who buy the product if that's the
question that you're asking man they
will rally around you and we live in
this amazing time and you've got to take
advantage of that and it really freaks
me out when people think that we're like
either the social movement is cresting
or it's behind us it's only gaining
steam the tv is going away the mobile
phone is becoming the television like
these changes are a one way ticket to
difference
now i don't know exactly what it's going
to look like i just know it's not going
to stop and it sure as hell isn't going
to go in reverse all right what is up
everybody i want to talk to you about my
good friend evan carmichael's book
right here built to serve i'm actually
going to read you a section there are
some amazing parts of this book and this
is one of my favorite it's under the
title comfort is the enemy of greatness
and it goes when you're comfortable you
don't get strong when you have plenty of
fresh air and no adversity you crumble
as soon as something gets hard it's
rarely the kids of rich parents who go
on to do great things even though they
have all the advantages that money
connections and education
can buy
why is that because they're too
comfortable people who are comfortable
don't create great things there it is
evan carmichael bringing the heat in his
book
built to serve get a copy only in the
process of gaining mastery will you find
passion so to me passion comes out of
it's kind of like love i don't believe
that love it needs a different word
unrequited love is a very different
neurological state than reciprocal love
so if you have unrequited love to me
that's something you really like i love
singing but i'm [ __ ] at it so
i have unrequited love i love singing
but singing does not love me back now i
could go down the process of gaining
mastery and then i may find that i have
a real passion for it because part of
it's going to become oh i'm gaining this
skill and this skill of singing allows
me to have an emotional impact not only
on myself but on other people i can make
them feel good i can change their mood i
can tell a story whatever it is that you
want to do with the music but when
you're able to do that and you're truly
good at it and it has the outcome that
you desire then it can become a passion
but to get a passion you've got to fight
through just ridiculous amounts of
boredom fatigue everything to truly
become good enough at it that it's a
skill that has utility people have got
to reject this notion that they have to
be protected from the outside and
putting all their time and energy into
that be the change you want to see in
the world if you want to see people
strong enough to withhold a better
weight then don't worry about trying to
fix systems just get tough watch how
people respond to you watch how your
kids look up to you watch how your
family members look up to you watch how
people turn to you and want help people
we have an innate desire to get strong
we don't have an innate desire to have
something else protect us all of us if
two buttons man one of them is you're
such a badass nothing can ever hurt you
you get it you know how to figure it out
you fight your way out of anything or
a magic fairy will follow behind you and
just waft things away
the terrifying thing is
this button the magic fairy is going to
get pressed a lot more than this button
but this button no one dies of suicide
with this button
this button must
race towards suicide and depression and
if you want to know why we're having a
pandemic of that and i don't want to
cheapen it because it's largely
microbiome and there's all kinds of
health things that are going on i'm not
taking that away but on the mental side
of what's driving a lot of people not
believing in that is we're just
culturally reinforcing that like we're
stuck we're trapped there's nothing we
can do that people don't understand the
fulfillment has to be earned you can't
tell someone to just love themselves you
have to tell them how they earn
self-respect you have to tell them that
doing hard sh
that you don't want to do and doing it
anyway that's exactly how you gain
self-worth you can't just tell someone
to feel worthy and man i want you more
than the next person like i
i spend an inordinate amount of my time
every week talking to a camera
trying to help people to touch their
lives for real like my wife and i made
so much money we could have actually
bought an island and retired and never
worked again
but that's not what i want like i want
that fulfillment i want to do hard i
want to touch people's lives i want to
lift them up i actually want to
transform and change them the single
most important part in learning to be
honest with yourself is to accept that
you must have self-esteem
and the problem is most people build
their self-esteem around something
stupid so most people build their
self-esteem around being right being
good being smart being worthy and they
see all of those as permanent traits and
so anything that challenges them being
smart which is my big one oh god even to
this day if i really want to get into a
bad place i'll just go hang around
people that are just legitimately
smarter than me and then focus on how
cool being smart is now i can be around
them when i value myself for being the
learner but the second i let myself slip
into just wanting to be cool for being
smart then being around those people is
like getting kicked in the face it sucks
man and so i had this i went through
this phase in my life that i call the
king of remedial jobs phase and i
wanted so this is post film school post
like realizing that i don't have talent
i just need to be smart man i just need
to build myself back up by being smart
and so i would apply for jobs like i
worked i sold video games retail
um and i sold insurance door-to-door i
did anything that i could where i knew
that the person interviewing me at some
point during the interview was gonna say
why are you applying for this job like
you're too smart for this and be like
i'm right where i need to be which is
crazy and sad but absolutely true and so
i did that for a couple years and in
that phase it was i just didn't want my
intelligence to be challenged so flash
forward now i'm working with these two
entrepreneurs they hire me as a
copywriter i'm in an entrepreneurial
environment for the first time and
they're
clearly smarter than me that that isn't
even up for debate and i'm
arguing with them for this idea because
i needed to win i just i couldn't take
another time where it's like they're
smarter than me they're smarter than me
so i was like all right i'm gonna win on
this idea and somewhere in the argument
i realized i was wrong and there was a
voice in my head screaming you're wrong
dude you are wrong you know you're wrong
shut up like stop pushing for this what
are you doing and i kept going and i
finally like whittled them down and they
finally just gave up and so they said
yep we'll do it your way fine whatever
and
right then and there's the one time in
my life that was truly a lightning rod
moment where my life can be divided
before and after
and that moment was realizing that i was
telling everybody that i wanted to get
rich
but the way i was acting was like i just
wanted to feel smart
and i thought hey no judgment i'm
totally cool whichever it is like we can
craft a life where that will be
wonderful so
if what you really want is to just be
smart and to feel smart all the time you
have to quit you've got to get out of
this environment because they make you
feel stupid all the time and that's not
a great place to be feeling badly about
yourself all the time for any reason
even if it's self-inflicted it's not a
bad scenario or it's not a good scenario
you've got to get out of it so i was
like okay so that's option one get out
of this scenario go back to being the
king of remedial jobs
or if you actually wanna get rich start
acting in accordance with it start
making decisions based on that and so i
was like okay well i'm gonna have to
give up my self-esteem i'm gonna have to
like stop worrying about feeling good
about myself and i was like oh
that is clearly a losing proposition
there is no way to come in and feel
horrible every day and think that i will
have the energy to see this through so i
was like god what else could i do i was
like well i guess i could build my
self-esteem around something that
is sort of impervious to being around
people that are smarter than me and what
would that be being the learner and i
thought okay well i could choose to do
that i could choose to build my
self-esteem around being
not
right but finding the right answer not
being smart but working hard to learn
and so that became just like the core of
my existence i decided in that moment
i'm going to start valuing myself for
how rapidly i can admit when i'm wrong
how much i learn how much time and
energy i put into learning and once i
switch that and i switch my identity and
my behaviors around to being the learner
then all of a sudden everything changed
and that's when i went on hockey stick
growth because all of a sudden if we
were arguing and i realized you were
right i'd be like dude he's right you're
totally right i see it oh my god thank
you so much and so i started earning a
reputation i never just backed into a
corner i never argued for something just
because it was my idea i was
legitimately on the hunt to find the
right answer and so now i'm getting the
internal feedback of hey you said that
you were going to always focus on being
the learner you're doing it you said
you'd always admit when you're wrong and
i would try to shorten that timeline
down so i wasn't like taking an hour to
finally admit it or even three minutes
that i was trying to get to it like dude
if i realized i was wrong three seconds
30 seconds max like i'm you know just
finally saying it look you're totally
right i'm with you yep i see it and then
the world was like whoa working with
this guy is awesome he's not trying to
take credit for other people's ideas he
will change on what he was saying in a
heartbeat when he you know he fights for
what he believes in but the second you
can convince him he's convinced and then
he moves on and it just became a really
awesome environment so that was hugely
transformative but it forces you to
constantly be on the lookout for where
am i wrong the reason that quest went so
fast wasn't just because we had done
something to our minds and gotten to the
point where we were so angry that we
were going to push us forward no matter
what
it was understanding the timing of the
marketplace and the technologies that
were emerging and the technology that
was emerging in 2009 when we first
started thinking about the company
everybody thought facebook was a joke
everybody thought it was a huge
distraction and what we understood was
it was just a megaphone
we didn't pass judgment on it
we just knew it was a megaphone
and it was a free megaphone
and if we could give them reason to say
something good within a couple of
minutes of an interaction with us they
could have a global audience and tell
people about that
so we saw that the timing was right
there and we also understood that people
want to have impact how do you think
about failure then
i'm not trying for me like to not have
the audacious goal to not really give it
a real shot and i know i'm constantly
gut-checking myself or am i playing at
building the next disney or am i
actually building the next disney that
means something to me so if i get to the
end of this and the world is clapping
for me and they're like oh my god you're
so amazing and look how far you went but
i know that i was only playing at trying
to get there and then i kept dialing it
back because i was getting too scared
that that would be failure for me i
don't think people have researched
cognitive behavioral therapy nearly
enough pattern interrupting is like
everything get better at pattern
interrupting than lebron is at shooting
like you just have to be a ninja like
you've got to be so hardcore you've got
to know about how to do that with
yourself so if i have a negative thought
that's recurring i just tell myself nope
you can't think this anymore so and
every time it will come up because i
can't stop myself from it popping up
into my conscious mind but you
absolutely can control how the next
thought goes the next thought can be oh
i'm
here's what i'll do with a negative
thought that's so rad i'm so glad this
negative thought appeared in my mind
because that reminds me to be grateful
for the fact that i'm friends with jay
shetty or that reminds me to be grateful
the fact i have a marriage that is so
insanely cool that like i legitimately
some days have to stop myself from just
curling up in a ball with her and just
chilling all day like that is i'm super
stoked even now jay it's so funny i had
to stop and think wait i'm going through
this list of things that i'm grateful
for what started this and i'm like oh
yeah the negative thought like that
actually just happened right now so you
can imagine in real life when like you
train yourself ah every time the
negative thought kicks up don't
don't sit in the emotion of the
negativity that it will bring
instead use it as a habit loop trigger
to think about something you're grateful
for and at first it feels so awkward and
it's like the negative thought just
keeps coming back but if you're diligent
and suddenly negative thoughts become a
habit loop trigger to gratitude to
positivity to repeating your rules about
i don't allow myself to think things
that tear me down so i'm not gonna think
about that even just saying that crowds
out that thought and telling other
people that hey this is what you're
doing it is unbelievable but this is why
i'm saying i'm literally just a
patchwork of all these like tools and
techniques that allow me to protect
myself from negative self-talk from
anxiety from depression i don't think
i've ever officially been in depression
but i've been super close enough to know
the feeling of staring into the void
which i don't think is accurate it feels
like the void is collapsing in around
you and just everything is meaningless
and it is all utterly hopeless and i've
had just enough of a glimpse of how
hopeless that is
to to get where people are in those
moments but anxiety that i've been in
the thick of
so that one i know and i've used cbt
cognitive behavioral therapy to do
interrupts on that um i have a very well
developed negative voice so i have had
to
use tools and techniques to stop that i
never would have become a successful
entrepreneur if i couldn't
learn to self-soothe and at one point
that was what i would have said was my
secret power that my secret power in
business was i can self-soothe faster
than anybody else focus on value only
value is sustainable
you want to make sure that you're
delivering value at every touch point
your customer service should deliver
value your marketing message should
deliver value your advertising in and of
itself should deliver value
your ads should be served to the people
who even though they can skip it after
four seconds they don't that's when
you're actually delivering value people
used to ask me like oh how do you get
rid of the negative voice i'm like i
don't know that you want to like the
negative voice is a powerful reminder to
practice gratitude it's
it's also a good reminder that maybe
something is wrong maybe you are doing
something wrong and you should adjust
and you should rethink i was just about
to say that sometimes your negative
voice is what protects you sometimes
very not all the time but there can be
times when it's protected in fact i'll
say it like this it it probably does
protect you all of the time but
it's
so repetitive
that
you touched this issue and now we're
into the 9 000th replay of this that's
where it becomes stupid and so the one
thing yep cool got it i do need to work
on that you're absolutely right um
and then just letting it go right and
not clinging on to it not beating
yourself up over it and all that stuff
but yeah it has a use which is why it's
so powerfully with us the man on top of
the mountain didn't fall there it's so
tempting to look at people that have
achieved the extraordinary and dismiss
them as being more talented than you
better than you but what you need to see
is the simple truth
they've worked harder than you
they've earned something that you
haven't yet earned but here's the great
news that's empowering once you
understand that they've just busted ass
once you understand that they've just
put in an inhuman amount of work and
that the only thing that distinguishes
the people that are on top of the
mountain the people that have really
done something that's going to last
is that they put in the effort they work
on themselves they understand it through
discipline and effort over time
that we can get better that is the human
condition that is the thing that i find
most beautiful about being a person is
it doesn't matter if you're bad today it
doesn't matter where you start it only
matters where you're willing to go and
the price that you're willing to pay to
get there and once you buckle down and
you assure yourself and back it up with
action that you're willing to pay any
price to achieve the things that you
want to achieve
then you'll really be living a limitless
life elon musk talks about in his
business it's all about breaking things
down to the physics
if you sell to people
the physics in your world is psychology
and understanding what motivates them
so your company needs to have a why
if you know simon sinek and his
brilliant book start with why
you'll know what we're talking about the
golden circle
most people know what they do they may
even know how they do it but they
oftentimes don't know why they do it
why did we launch quest nutrition
because we wanted to end metabolic
disease
now nobody knew that from looking at a
protein bar
but our marketing material was about
that
we didn't do features and benefits we
said stop sacrificing
we said you should hold food companies
to a new standard it's ridiculous that
food companies aren't
engineering new equipment to make food
that's both good for you
and delicious
it's just ridiculous nobody's held their
feet to the fire people have been buying
the same junk products for years they're
not going to change unless you force
them to and so we came along and said
we're going to be the bearer of
standards
we know why we're doing what we're doing
so i can't release a product that has
sugar in it why because that's not going
to end metabolic disease and that is my
driver i show up to work every day not
thinking about making it rain and
counting my money i'm not swimming in it
like scrooge mcduck i'm coming every day
thinking about two people my mom and my
sister
and i ask a very simple question is this
advantageous for my mom and my sister
yes or no if it is i do it if it's not i
don't now a lot of times what's
advantageous for my mom and my sister
was really expensive it was super
annoying to have to do it because it was
like you watch your private margins like
oh god
but it becomes an easy filter and every
business has to have a filter every
business needs to know what they say yes
to and what they say no to and if you
don't have that blinding guiding light
when you scale you will fall apart
and the reason you will fall apart your
customers won't know who you are they
won't know how to communicate your
message to somebody else your employees
won't know who you are they won't know
what to communicate to each other let
alone the outside world
so it has got to be blinding you have to
be able to write it down it has to be
super clear it's got to be direct and
it's got to be meaningful
and it has to be real
it's got to actually be something that
drives you what we all have to
understand is at the end of the day the
only thing that matters is how good is
your product whether you're trying to
build a company or you're trying to be a
kick-ass employee or you're trying to be
the best parent of all time at the end
of the day the only thing that matters
is getting good the only thing that
matters is actually delivering an
extraordinary performance until you get
to that point where you can actually
knock it out of the park until you get
to the point where you can
captivate people with what you're able
to do you haven't gotten anywhere if you
want to be great if you want to leave a
legacy if you want to be remembered
you've got to focus on the acquisition
of skills you have to focus on actually
getting good that's the only thing
that's really going to capture people's
imagination we all come to a
relationship with like expectations
about how we think people should act and
unfortunately we don't recognize our
expectations as expectations we
recognize them as truth this is how the
world is it is how the world should be
and when somebody we think that they
have those same beliefs and values and
rules and all that and so given this
scenario there's only one way to act
that is certainly obvious and so when
the person doesn't act like that we take
it personally like whoa do you not
respect me do you not love me do not
care about me and it just isn't that
they have a different set of beliefs and
rules there's enough nuance difference
that they're not if they're intending to
hurt you you have a whole different set
of problems but assuming that they're
not intending to hurt you then you have
a communication problem so lisa and i
actually define our terms
so we have a few words in our
marriage that they mean something so if
i say hey baby it's important to me that
you leave that you know glass of water
on the table
then there she just wouldn't move it
period simple as like the the word
important like comes in all caps with
exclamation points glowing red like
that's like when we say it like it's a
drop whatever you're doing like it's
important that you do x y z now the big
thing is when you define a word like
that you can't ever abuse it so like i
would never say it's important to me
that you leave it you know it's got to
be it's just extraordinary like how many
times do i tell her something's
important in a year
i don't know six seven times in a year
so it's like it's really gotta be
limited and then another one is promise
if i say i promise i'm gonna do that
dude i'm going to do
that like there's no two ways about it
so you never throw a round promise ever
under any circumstance and so dude it's
like you really really have to be
hardcore and so and the other way that
we use promises um if
if
she says you know how does this dress
look on me i'm like yeah it looks great
and she's like you promise
then it's like all right all right it
makes you look fat what can i say i mean
it's like but then you you cut to like
the chase on something now the thing is
you can't say that all the time you
can't be like how's this dress make me
look fine promise uh what do you think
of this dinner you like it yeah i love
it promise like if you're doing that it
loses everything but if you're saving it
for like in fact god i almost don't
remember the last time i asked lisa to
promise something like that um but
you know that you haven't we certainly
use it more in the early days of our
marriage but even then like how many
times a year three or four i mean it's
like but it really forces you to respect
these things you make sacred in your
relationship for the person who's stuck
for the guy or gal
who's in the cubicle who's hates their
job is in a dysfunctional relationship
is in debt whatever the case may be
desperately wants a way out a way
forward a lifeline
where does that process begin for you
like what is the advice that you give
that person
so it begins with believing or
acknowledging that humans are the
ultimate adaptation machine so the the
thing that has made us the apex predator
is not that we're stronger um it's not
even that we're smarter in fact the the
quote often attributed to darwin is that
oh it's the survival of the fittest he
actually didn't say that
what he did say was it's not the
strongest of the species that survived
nor the most intelligent but rather the
most adaptive to change now the reason
that humans are the apex of all apexes
is because we are the most adaptive
species to change so if you know that
then it becomes infinitely less
important who you are today and what
matters is who do you want to become and
what price and the price being the time
and energy that you're going to put into
acquiring the skills to become that
person so imagine the person that you
want to be how would they act and then
start acting like that if the person
that you want to be would leave their
job and
you know regardless of whether they had
a safety net burn the ships and go after
something new then that's what you
should do if the person that you want to
be would start working nights and
weekends because they very much value
having a stable income that they can
provide for their family or themselves
whatever
but are going to be disciplined and
spend nights and weekends to get the
skill set to go be more valuable
somewhere else or to start their own
company whatever then do that social
media is going to allow you to have real
meaningful relationships with your
customers i will tell you one very fast
in the very early days of quest when all
of us had to go out and actually make
the bars i'm out making bars our chief
marketing officers out making bars like
everybody's out there there would be
periods of time where we wouldn't
respond to somebody on facebook but this
one woman started responding and we
thought wow that's so weird like
is did somebody create a fake account
like is that one of you guys everyone's
like no man we didn't do it that's a
real person and she would tell people
like oh don't worry i'm sure they'll get
back to you quickly they're really great
company and we were so and this is like
early 2010 we're like what is happening
and so we reached out and said hey we
want to put you on payroll she's like i
don't want to be on payroll
and i'm like whoa okay now i'm getting
freaked out like
what do you want and she was like i just
want you to continue to deliver a
service i'm a nutritionist and i use
your bars with a lot of people i just
want to make sure that you're around so
we developed this really cool
relationship with her we all got to know
her she held us to a standard she was
not always nice she was always fair but
she wasn't always nice if we were doing
something poorly from a product
standpoint like we
weights and measures will let you ship
product that's heavy you just can't ship
light okay so imagine you beg your
doritos your bag of doritos is gonna be
heavy it's never going to be light
now so we're thinking okay cool we have
to comply with weights and measures but
we're a health and fitness company so
people like if i'm buying 60 grams and
that's what i have in my diet plan i
want to make sure i'm eating 60 grams
and not 65. and so she would call us out
on it so we ended up buying a piece of
equipment because of that relationship
that we had with this woman that we
never met
and then one day she went silent
we wrote to her mom hey is everything
okay and her mom said she passed away
she was like
28
and i got like really emotional and i'd
never met her and i'm not like that guy
but i got legitimately emotional and i
wrote
a manifesto and i said to everyone in
the company basically we exist to serve
these people every one of them is trying
to do something that we may know nothing
about
and they're using our products and so we
started celebrating her name's joy
ramita we've been doing it for four
years now the joyramita superfan award
we bring somebody in that's been amazing
to the community we just give them a big
blowout party at our headquarters giving
behind the scenes access to cool stuff
just to say thank you
and that's when we really realized it
it may not be the kind of relationship
you have with your mom or your brother
or your sister or your spouse but it's
meaningful man in a way that business
relationships haven't been since like
the local
general store and you saw the same
people come in every day it really is
like if you can flip that switch in your
mind and see it as something beautiful
i'm telling you it will open you up to a
whole new way of interacting with your
customers because there's a lot of
amazing stuff going on in your
communities that you may not even know
about or that you could really feed into
and build into something amazing and if
you stay focused on it being a community
of people that are supporting themselves
each other and your company then you can
do some pretty incredible things being
honest even when it sucks because let me
tell you how many times it's gonna be
where if you just lied
oh god it would be so much easier and
you would probably get away with it and
but it the way that i explain lying to
people is you get away with it fifty
percent of the time and so it tempts you
to think it's a good strategy
but the other fifty percent of the time
it is cratering trust
and once you can't trust the person all
hope is lost
and there's nothing more beautiful than
being in a relationship with somebody
who makes you feel like they're your
number they're number one
and that you totally trust them and lisa
wrote this um instagram post about how
she could see a photo of me with my arm
around a woman or resting my head on a
villain or hugging her or whatever and
she it wouldn't even make her radar to
question it
so
that's the fun for us is having that
level of trust now it's like um i think
it's buffett that said you spend your
entire life building your reputation
only takes five seconds to lose it so
it's like we're so careful we for 18
years we've been earning trust with each
other so like dude so especially when i
was back at quest and
it was
women would come and flirt and hit on me
because they wanted something and wanted
to be sponsored by the company or
whatever and i was around bikini literal
bikini models like all the time
and so if ever there was going to be a
moment of insecurity for my wife it
would have been that period
a she wasn't insecure and b i the
thought of throwing away 18 years of
shared experience of all that trust and
everything it's sex is like rad and
super exciting and i love it the most
but like compared to what i would have
to give up for something like that it
just doesn't rate on the radar so
and by the way thing something like i'm
saying now which most people would hide
from their spouse oh that yeah of course
i find other people attracted what are
you talking about like we just openly
talk about that like she'll nudge me and
be like oh my god anything she's hot
it's like that's just
we set up early on in the relationship
to be aggressively ourselves and one
thing that we both were really honest
about was i was like look it is human
nature you are going to find other guys
attractive and i will actually trust you
more if you
admit when you find somebody attractive
than if you say something stupid like i
only have eyes for you oh really you're
the only human in all of history to like
uh you know transcend their human nature
like it doesn't make sense yeah and then
that's a super fragile place to be
because what happens if i get older what
happens if i get injured or scarred like
then i'm really supposed to believe that
suddenly you're more attracted to
somebody with a scar than somebody
without like it doesn't make sense so we
all live in this fragile bubble of well
as long as they lie to me it's okay and
as long as i'm willing to believe and
even though secretly i know it's a lie
and then it's the more pious than now
like oh my god she's thinking all these
nice things about me but i'm actually
finding other people attractive and i'm
just lying about it and so then you're
like wait if i'm lying about it is she
lying about it and so it just
it erodes all that trust so from the
jump we were like look you're going to
find other people attractive i'm going
to find other people attractive but let
me introduce you to this magical word
called commitment
now i'm with you because i love you
because i respect you
but i'm also with you because i'm
committed to you and so you don't have
to worry that i'm going to be looking
over my shoulder for a more attractive
woman there are going to be more
attractive women than you for sure
especially as you age
who
cares you're my wife
we have shared an experience we've
shared a life we've built this around
each other and commitment means
something to me going back to having
that code that you live by and the rules
and the code that i live by i'm never
going to betray that yeah so it's like
we've always said i may break up with
you one day because i'm not saying that
like oh there's nothing you could do
that would make me break up with you for
sure there is but i'm never going to
cheat on you
i may come and say i'm breaking up with
you because i'm going to go have sex
with somebody else but i'm absolutely
not going to go have sex with somebody
behind your back never going to happen
so like having that trust and knowing
who the other person is like all that
stuff is is super meaningful and look
there's just more and more and more
stuff but
those are some big ones how do you
process issues how do you do you have a
system on what you go through something
happens something comes up in your brain
is there a step process you go through
yes what is it starts with the goal so
what is my goal um well first it starts
with clearing the emotion because
probably whatever i was told just had
some emotion i recentered myself the
thing that i probably repeat to myself
the most is you can do anything you set
your mind to on a long enough timeline
so i know i can learn anything so if the
thing that hits me is overwhelming
because i'm scared i don't know how to
do it you can do anything you set your
mind to so at the end of this thinking
through is going to be the question are
you willing to set your mind to it or
not um and then i identify okay what's
my goal does this move me towards my
goal yes or no i think through the
process of has somebody done it is there
already a well-laid path from where i'm
at to actually completing this which is
how i decided that we were going to take
on disney because looking at the only
studio ever in the history of time to be
disciplined enough to only tell one kind
of story from a thousand different
angles so much so that they gave birth
to americana
is disney no other studio everyone else
is all over the map if i say i'm going
to go see a sony movie or a paramount
movie you don't know anything about it
but if i say i'm going to go see a
disney movie you already know something
so their name brand means something so i
could see oh there's a path from where
i'm at to the impact that i want to have
so i throw that out just as a reminder
of the path that i'm walking more than i
have some particular obsession with
disney
fascinating and by the way in your in
your mind do you see it already that
vision becoming a reality no question no
question no question about it for sure
and look i have days of where i'm like
how the [ __ ] am i actually gonna do this
but then you come back to you can learn
anything you set your mind to so just
keep marching forward your mind begins
to lay down patterns over time neurons
that fire together wire together so if
you let's say you want to do public
speaking and you get nervous every time
you're about to public speak then you
begin to develop this pavlovian response
of anxiety as you go to speak but you
could interrupt that pattern you could
find ways whether it's taking a much
more confident posture which there's all
kinds of amazing research on how just
your posture changing your posture
creates a different internal reality
going back to your creating the state
that you're in if you're sitting like
this and you're allowing your face to
take on this really droopy sad posture
it's very different what you feel
is very different than if you take an
open confident posture if you hold your
face in a very optimistic upbeat i dare
you try to be really pissed off and
laugh out loud it just doesn't work
understanding that all of that stuff is
intentionality at play it's
you
choosing what you think it's you
choosing what you believe it's you
choosing what you feel and all of that
stuff has a material impact on the world
around you take meditation
i eschewed meditation for years i
thought it was the dumbest thing in the
world i tried it didn't make any sense
to me until someone explained what i was
really doing was gaining control over my
autonomic nervous system because right
now so much of your life happens in the
subconscious the vast majority of the
data that your brain processes
is done subconscious in fact the
conscious mind is the last person to
know if you guys have seen david
eagleman and what he talks about how
there's all this neurological activity
going on things that are known things
that are discarded things that are moved
towards and the last person to know
about it is your conscious mind despite
the fact that he's going to take credit
for all of it your conscious mind is
actually the last to know so being able
to take control of
the autonomic nervous system is so
powerful it's going to allow you to
center yourself before giving a speech
it's going to allow you to calm yourself
before taking a test it's going to allow
you to perform at a higher level take
the navy seals the navy seals
teach breathing exercises the navy seals
teach meditative practices because when
you get into a combat situation and
things are flying and moving really fast
and it is literally a life or death
situation you've got to learn to calm
your autonomic nervous system and if you
can't do that if you can't lower your
rate of breathing if you can't calm your
heart rate if you can't push the blood
back into your prefrontal cortex so that
you can make
the right decisions and quickly
you're screwed
so
learning that this is all intention
learning that your brain is housed in a
shell and it never sees the light of day
it never actually encounters sound it
encounters electrical and chemical
signals and from that it paints the best
version of reality that it can but it
isn't the total reality and it isn't
objective
once you accept that once you get that
there's even a crack in that door of
subjectivity and that you can control
that subjectivity then all of a sudden
your beliefs become things to control
and manipulate to move and construct
around something that serves you
list the beliefs that you have about
yourself and put them in two different
sides on one side i want you to list the
things that empower you and move you
forward on the other side i want you to
list the things that
demotivate or demean you and move you
away from your goals and then i want you
to look at the balance my guess is most
of you have more beliefs about yourself
that are detrimental that make you less
of who you are than you have on the
positive side of things that make you
bigger that make you more confident that
give you the courage and the audacity to
move forward once you realize both of
those are fake both of those are merely
a representation that your mind has
chosen to give you and they're not
objectively true then you can realize
hey i can change these i can choose to
believe things that empower me i can
choose to ignore things that move me
backwards or change them
but it's all a construct get control of
your mind it's so powerful in fact the
most powerful form of mind control
is control over one's own mind you are
first of all never going to be right all
the time yet you have to move forward as
if you are right you have to come to a
conclusion about what is the most sure
path to your goal and be marching down
that path
this is advanced clash but you also have
to be able to go am i right
so at the same time you're racing
forward as
fast as you can you've got to
occasionally check yourself and say is
this actually working is there data that
i can look at what empirical evidence do
i have that i'm actually going in the
right direction now you want to know
where i spend the vast majority of my
time
it's in that if i'm not actively
executing and even sometimes when i am
actively executing i'm i'm doing these
little checks what's the data what data
points can i look at so not like it
feels right not i want to do it is there
data that i can look at that tells me my
mother going in the right direction or
i'm not so i have that feeling all the
time i'm trying actively to delude
myself since the people that are most
delusional are the happiest i'm trying
to delude myself to make sure that i'm
going and going with enthusiasm i'm
trying to delude myself that despite the
fact that i know
next to nothing of what i'm going to
ultimately need to know in order to
succeed that i keep going that is
fundamental and critical and then whilst
i'm deluding myself i'm checking to make
sure that that delusion never gets out
of hand that i'm still grounded in
reality that i'm still checking myself
against
data and all of those things are going
to be what allow you to keep this from
spilling over into something that's
counterproductive because there is a
level of delusion that's useful and then
there's a level of delusion that is um
it's going to break you down it's going
to take you in the wrong direction so
you've really got to check yourself
against that now getting good at that is
not easy but leaning on data data data
data what is the external world telling
you
and not being afraid to see that the
external world is telling you that
you're going in the wrong direction and
then being able to pivot i own a
nutrition company but i am not a thought
leader i'm an influencer i have a
thought leader that i trust that i
listen to happens to be my business
partner
but i'm the one that then translates
that for the masses
so when you're trying to build a
community the person you're looking for
at the top you want to make sure the
thought leaders believe in your product
so you're going to send it to them
you're going to explain it to them
you're going to make sure that your
product is real because they will smell
be us bs a mile away now if they're into
it and then you go after the influencers
who will then ask the thought leaders
what they think thought leaders will
give it the green light the influencers
then will begin telling the masses
influencers in my world are people with
six-pack abs they're the guy at the gym
they're the girl at the beach in the
bikini people that other people walk up
to and say whoa what did you do to get
in such great shape and we wanted to
make sure their answer was i ate a quest
bar
and that was how we grew the business
and we wrote individualized letters to a
bunch of influencers and a bunch of
thought leaders saying hey we know who
you are which by the way we were very
sincere it was all real we know who you
are
we think this product brings value to
you and the people that follow you and
we just want you to talk about it if you
hate it tell people you hate it and if
you love it tell them you love it all
right you want to find your thousand
screaming fans
the thousand screaming fans are those
influencers that are going to get
attention for you
identifying them most people think of
these people as getting to your thousand
screaming fans for you but what they
should be thinking about is this now i'm
sure most of you knew the people in the
previous slide i'm sure most of you
don't know any of the people in this
slide but this woman here anybody know
who jenna marbles is
show of hands i hear a couple yeses
there we go all right jenna marbles has
a daily reach of 20 million people
that's bigger than the biggest show on
tv that's crazy
this is the world of social
it seems hidden to most people over 35
but it is in plain sight
these are the people that you're going
to be going after jenna marbles we sent
her
dogs sweatshirts
and a whole stack of our product now why
did we send her dog sweatshirts because
her dogs are little chihuahuas they're
skinny as hell and they always look cold
so we had some custom-made sweatshirts
sent to her she loved them so much she
started promoting
the bars and showing people what we had
sent her and thanking us now no money
exchanged hands
it was just us doing something that she
would think was cool that her followers
would think was cool and we got to tap
into that reach that's the power of
social
i won't belabor these points socialists
still despite what you may think largely
free it's real-time connection raw
feedback think 30 years ago how much you
would have paid for real-time feedback
from your actual customers written right
to you telling you if they think you're
amazing or a jerk or whatever they may
think it's absolutely incredible and
they want you to respond and win them
back over it is amazing it lets you test
things rapidly which is amazing and it
lets you build a community very rapidly
and connecting to something other than
the money i was finally able to really
see and understand what it was that
motivated me and i confessed to them
that money was not my highest priority
in business my highest priority was
camaraderie i wanted to connect i wanted
to bring something of value to the
customer i wanted to think about the
customer i wanted to be myself and i
wanted to market in a way that was
inclusive and created a community
and in that community
we could do something more than just
sell products
and so we decided to sell that company
because they felt the same and they
wanted to do something based on passion
they wanted to have the energy and
excitement to see things through and for
three very different reasons we decided
to form quest nutrition now as i
mentioned i grew up in a morbidly obese
family so for me
i was never going to chase money again
and i told them that i was only going to
focus on value creation and it had to be
something that i had a deep and personal
connection to
so for me i started thinking every day
about saving my mom and my sister
my mom and my sister are both morbidly
obese and have been essentially my
entire life
and i knew that i was going to lose them
too soon if i couldn't solve the problem
of how they ended up there i wanted to
give them food that they could choose
based on taste
and it happened to be good for them the
only thing that would get me out of bed
15 years before i'm capable of building
a billion dollar company
the only thing that got me out of bed
was shame
so
you have to understand that people had
not misidentified me this is not a story
of someone who was born extraordinary
people just couldn't see it that i was
secretly this amazing person who was
just waiting for their opportunity to
shine this was somebody who was lazy as
had no idea what they were going to do
with their life
i had no idea how i was going to pull it
off i was absolutely terrified every
time i looked in the mirror i saw me
staring back and i knew how lazy i was i
knew how afraid i was i knew how
insecure i was i knew that at my core i
wanted people to like me and i was
terrified that they had every reason in
the world not to like me but instead of
becoming someone who was worthy of
self-respect who was worthy of their
respect
all i was trying to do was campaign i
was trying to posture i was trying to
create the illusion that i was something
because that seemed like i could do it
fast instead of just buckling down and
doing the hard-ass work of becoming
somebody new
because i had one failed
misunderstanding
i believed
that my talent
and intelligence were fixed traits
i was born a certain way
and life was about making the most of
what i'd been born with
what i did not yet understand
is the reason humans
are the ultimate apex predator
the reason that we have taken over the
globe in a way that no other species has
is because we are the ultimate
adaptation machine
darwin is often misquoted as saying it's
the strongest of the species that
survive he did not say that what he said
was it's neither the strongest of the
species that survive nor the most
intelligent but rather the most adaptive
to change
getting good at being strategic and this
is why i'm always reading business books
i'm always reading about the mind and
i'm always trying to learn about what
industry i'm going into so right now
right now boys and girls
i am
enmeshed
in the world of comics
and i'm trying to ask and answer some
very fundamental questions about why the
industry is so broken so first of all
you have to understand it well enough to
see that it is broken then second you've
got to understand it well enough that
you can actually figure out what are the
real answers to this so diving in
reading what you can finding out who are
the influencers in that space who are
the real thought leaders who's got
insight into this that's going to be
incredibly usable once you have that
then you begin compiling your own world
view of that thing but you've got to
practice that you've got to get and i
really stop mid-stream there there's a
whole universe
that goes around how you get good at
being strategic and breaking things down
you need something else that's going to
get you off the hook and it has to be
that core belief system in your life a
belief system that you put in place when
you were emotionally sober and you said
to yourself i'm making a pledge i do and
believe that which moves me towards my
goals period
not when it's convenient
always
and that becomes a guiding light in my
life if the guiding light in your life
is that you only do and believe that
which moves you towards your goals
when you get into that loop of beating
yourself up and thinking that you're
worthless or that you're never going to
make it
[Music]
remember that that belief does not serve
you
and you don't do things that don't serve
you
and not to rat anybody out but do you
know how many people just
today
have broke down in tears in front of me
and the punch line is always the same
they don't think they're going to make
it
they become convinced they're more lost
than other people they're less capable
than other people that while other
people are going to have these beautiful
lives not them
here's the irony
everyone feels that way
everyone goes through moments of doubt
and despair
so you need something to protect your
mindset against that loop because it
will chip away at you
and the belief is
very simple
you don't do things that don't serve you
the first thing you need to do whenever
somebody wants something they know what
they want they've got a clear goal
they're prepared to do the work but they
just find there's pretty radical
inconsistencies as they're trying to
move along that path to really get
something going
number one is that you need to
really get amped up about why that goal
matters to you because once you know why
the goal matters that's going to be that
thing that gives you meaning and purpose
that turns into a passion that allows
you to show up and keep doing it when
you're bored because boredom kills more
dreams than failure i just promise you
you just get to the point where it's
such a grind and you've got to do it day
after day month after month year after
year it's just like it really drags on
it's like that old outcast song forever
forever ever forever ever it's like it's
easy to do something once maybe you can
do it for a week but when you have to
just keep at the grind then you really
have to have a strong why so figuring
out why is it that you care enough about
this because by the way if you don't
care enough about it to do all this go
find something that you do care enough
about to go after because you can do
anything you want in life
just
not
everything
now if you're as angered by that notion
as i am you realize whatever it is
you're going to give yourself over to
and do all the way it needs to be
something that you are really on fire
about now
getting on fire about something you're
not born with that you cultivate that
fire so you're going to pick something
starts as an interest you're going to
pick it engage with it fan the flames of
that fire by talking about it to
yourself to your friends to your family
to anybody who will listen about why it
matters to you and then you go hard on
that so like for me i'm trying to build
the next disney but why why am i trying
to build the next disney
because i've worked with so many people
in the inner cities that were
extraordinary far smarter than i am and
they're doing nothing with their life
why because they don't have the right
frame of reference their mindset
is so limited that even though they have
all of this natural skill that they
could build upon and turn into something
absolutely extraordinary they're not
doing it because they're not thinking
about themselves and the world in the
right way okay i'm not prepared to live
in that world right now in america the
number one predictor of your future
success is your zip code okay i want to
introduce you to a word maybe you know
what maybe don't called an animus
something that that pisses you off
enough that it animates you to take
action now you want to find something a
spark of something and really turn that
into this raging inferno of i am not
prepared to live in a world where that's
true and now i'm going to show up every
day and i'm going to fight make sure you
focus it
get it specific to a person don't let it
be abstract who's someone you know and
love that's struggling with that thing
that you want to put an end to do you
have a mom that's struggling with
depression a brother that has massive
anxiety whatever the case may be there's
something
out there that animates you that you
want to fix
and you attach that to a person that you
love and care for why so that on a
friday at 2am when you're exhausted and
you're bored and you know you need to
show up and have the discipline to see
this through
you don't want to be thinking in the
abstract
you want to be thinking very concretely
about a person who is struggling with
that thing and then you can fight for
them i always said at quest i was trying
to end metabolic disease because my mom
and my sister were morbidly obese and i
didn't want them to die so a friday on a
2 a.m i wasn't showing up thinking about
protein bars i showed up thinking about
them and suddenly when you're fighting
for somebody like that and it's personal
you'll have the energy that you need to
see it through i believe
the very meaning of life
is to find out how many skills you can
acquire that have utility
and then put that utility to the test in
service of someone else
it's what the ancient greeks call techne
i've worked my ass off for this set of
skills they are unique to me
and they help other people and in being
able to help other people was something
that i worked very hard for i feel good
about myself
and i will make you guys one promise
right here today the game you're playing
please listen to this so that you don't
end up wasting years of your life like i
did mine
the game that you're playing is not
success
the game you're playing is not money
the game that you're playing
is brain chemistry
it's about fulfillment
the only thing ultimately that's ever
going to matter in your life
is how you feel about yourself
when you're by yourself my father-in-law
once gave me this advice
he was the first person i met that had
really been successful and he said
what you want to do
is know more about any situation than
anyone else in the world
and i actually remember what i said to
him i said yeah my boss doesn't really
think like that
i have since apologized to my
father-in-law for giving me such an
amazing piece of information and me
doing nothing with it for like six years
but once i understood that the only path
to excellence is to truly become an
expert the only path to excellence is to
actually get good at something
these days in a hyper-connected world
where within minutes of an interaction
with you your product whatever someone
can have a global audience and tell
people what they think that product
better be awesome
but the great news is the world's been
democratized now
you no longer have to have
150 million dollar ad budget in order to
cut through the clutter in our first
eight months we were profitable at month
six in our first eight months we didn't
invest more than ten thousand dollars
because we had a product that actually
delivered value
our marketing message delivered value
and if you focus on that if you focus on
making something that's better than what
other people are doing now you really
can cut through the noise very very
quickly
and you gotta grind baby grind
that was me for almost two years
people see where the company's gotten
they see me up giving speeches but what
they don't see is that in the middle of
the night my hands used to wake me up
cramping closed
because all day i was making protein
bars and in the very beginning we were
running the technology company during
the day and then going and making
protein bars by hand at night with
rolling pins and handheld blades that we
cut the bars and then wrapped them three
at a time we wrapped them three at a
time we would make 1200 bars i think
nine of us made 1200 bars over a six or
seven hour period now in a day we make
1.5 million
but that's where it starts it starts
with the willingness
to persist
long after it's boring it starts with
the ability to focus
on your end customer
long after you're exhausted it starts
with the ability to think about those
people that you really want to serve
when you're scared and have no idea how
you're going to pull it off
but you chose to believe
that you could do it you chose to
believe that and because you chose to
believe that you were able to achieve
excellence this is the central mantra of
my life
it doesn't matter who you are today
it really doesn't so if you feel like
you're incapable of something maybe you
are today
but just because you're incapable of
something today doesn't mean that you're
not capable of learning that thing so
it's not about who you are today
it's about who you want to become
and the price you're willing to pay to
get there
and i promise you
the day that you're willing to pay any
price
you'll achieve what you want to achieve
i knew exactly
what i wanted i had my why i had my goal
and it was very specific and this is the
thing about goals they have to be
incredibly specific and my goal was to
end metabolic disease
not sell a lot of protein bars that was
not the goal i wanted to end metabolic
disease and that informed every choice
that we made as entrepreneurs every time
that we had to answer a hard question
one that might impact profitability or
how late we were going to have to work
or what we were going to have to do and
it almost always was difficult including
by the way we had to become our own
manufacturers which we did not want to
do
we wanted to outsource it we just wanted
to be marketers but nobody would make
the bar for us
or they would but they said that we had
to add sugar to it and we asked a simple
question will that help end metabolic
disease yes or no if yes we'll do it if
no we won't and it wouldn't so we didn't
it starts with that specific goal
and then because i had my why
my hands cramping closed in the face of
doing something to save my mom and my
sister it was not a hard choice in fact
i wouldn't have been able to look myself
in the eye and say i was not able to
help them
because it was hurting my hands
right it sounds ridiculous when you say
it like that but most people don't have
a personal tie to what they're doing
mother teresa has an amazing quote no
one will act for the many
but people will act for the one
and so as you guys go into your jobs and
you think about what you're trying to do
find a way to stop making it a job find
a way to make it a calling a vocation
something that really meets that why
your desire to connect or do something
great for people what it's really going
to take for you to get to that next
level is to understand that the person
that you are
has gotten you as far as is ever going
to get you
so you've got to become a new person
you literally have to adapt
now the great news is like we talked in
my first talk that is what humans are
wired to do
humans are the ultimate adaptation
machine the reason that we are the only
species that you can find in every
corner of the globe at one point james
cameron was literally at the bottom of
the marianas trench we have sent human
beings to the moon we are going to send
human beings to mars
and the reason we're going to be able to
do that is we can adapt to our
surroundings
there was a woman who swam the bearing
straight
really think about this the bering
strait is the space between russia and
alaska so you can imagine it's not quite
a swim in the bahamas
to make the swim
she had to change
her fat
from what's known as white adipose
tissue
to brown fat
brown fat is more thermogenic so it
actually kicks off heat
to do that for over a year she had to
expose herself routinely to cold
temperatures sleeping in the winters in
alaska with the window open
but in doing that she actually put her
body through an adaptation response her
body got the message adapt or die so it
adapted and when you're willing to put
yourself under those kinds of stresses
to become that new thing you want to
become to be the new person that you
want to be to go farther than anyone you
know has ever gone to be the goat it is
possible
but it demands a price
it demands a price
and what this weekend is about it's
about you deciding for yourself
where do you want to go
and what price are you willing to pay to
get there
there's no right answer
there's no wrong answer
there's just clarity
there's just clarity
don't judge yourself if you don't want
to play on a world stage
don't judge yourself if you're not
willing to pay an extraordinary price
just get the clarity
of what you want
and what you need to do to get there
when you do that
then you're going to be able to
construct a narrative about who you are
and that narrative becomes everything if
you want to do something extraordinary
you have one job
leave your fellow humans in awe
now when you think about holy sh my job
as a parent as an entrepreneur as an
athlete as a speaker as a whatever you
want to be
you've got to get so good at that thing
that when people see you do it
you make them experience the most potent
human emotion and that is awe
to get that good
is a terrifying journey
of self-discovery
and confronting
who you really are
because you cannot make change until you
acknowledge where you're actually at
now why because it's not some
new age woo thing it is for real like if
you understand where you're weak then
you know where to spend your time
building skills
to me the gap between where you are now
and where you want to go is a gap of
skill set
and once i realized that and i made the
choice
to believe that this whole brain
plasticity thing was real even though it
was being hotly debated then i could
shift my self-esteem from being smart
right
good
worthy
to being that of the learner
the learner is the only identity that i
have ever found that is anti-fragile
as naseem teleb says things that are
robust that are strong that are tough
that can take just a lot of abuse before
they break they are still ultimately
defined by their breaking point
something that is anti-fragile on the
other hand is something that the more
you attack it the more it is pounded on
the stronger it gets
now imagine being able to build
a belief system
the thing that you build your
self-esteem around if all of that
we're tied to something that is truly
anti-fragile that the more somebody
comes after it the more robust it
becomes
being a learner is that answer we went
through a whole debate about what is the
next company going to be and it was one
of those where it had to be something
that we cared about you know we had
started this whole gyration of selling
the technology company because i was so
pissed and so tired of chasing money and
i wanted to do something that i believed
in i wanted to do something that
mattered that had impact so the only
reason that i was interested in getting
into nutrition was because i felt that
it one it could save the two people that
i was most worried about in the world
and two i thought that it could address
what i saw as the greatest health the
greatest health crisis we face as a
species quite frankly if somebody's
giving you advice about something that
they have not done in their own life
then they have basically a zero
believability score and somebody who has
a zero believability score shouldn't be
pushing their idea like they know
something they should be asking a lot of
questions now when you're talking to
somebody that's done ray dalio saying is
three times or more if they've
successfully done something three times
or more than they have believability in
that area so you want to find people
that have believability that really know
what they're talking about
and
then you should listen you should ask a
lot of questions you should really come
to understand it if they haven't done
that they may still have amazing ideas
but what you need because the
um you know sometimes a novice has
really fresh insights because they're
just not stuck in the dogmatic ways of
thinking that experts usually get into
but you need to be thinking about it
differently so rather than listening to
their conclusions you should be trying
to understand their methodology how did
they get there what is their process
their reasoning for making the statement
that they're making now if their
reasoning is sound then their conclusion
may very well be worthwhile but you have
to understand their reasoning so one of
those two things so either they are an
expert in that area and thusly you
should listen or they are not and you
should only be thinking about what their
process was to get to that conclusion
then you have to be able to derive your
own assessment as to whether or not you
should listen to them there's not going
to be anything more empirical than that
fulfillment is what matters
it is a neurochemistry state
the game that you're playing is not
success it is not money it is not legacy
it is
neurochemistry it's feeling good about
yourself right now today in this moment
now
the absolute foundational building block
to fulfillment is progress now it i
don't mean progress in worldly pursuits
i mean humans are an active species that
are absolutely designed
to learn
adapt and grow
we are the ultimate adaptation machine
now when nature wants us to do something
it incentivizes that thing with pleasure
so
if we're the ultimate adaptation machine
designed to learn grow and get better
then it's going to make that process
intensely pleasurable now what it
doesn't incentivize is
the
obsession over where other people are
whether or not we have unique ideas
whether or not we're valuable none of
that is going to bring you joy okay as
they say comparison is the thief of joy
so hey if you really want to [ __ ] with
yourself jump in the instagram feed and
look how other people are crushing it
and obsess over that
if on the other hand you want to really
have a deep and lasting sense of
fulfillment jump in the instagram feed
find people that motivate and inspire
you to be a better version of yourself
not to attain worldly success but to
actuate your potential to ask yourself a
very simple question what is it that i
am excited by what am i motivated by
what jazzes me up regardless of whether
or not a jazz is anybody else up and now
i'm gonna go get good at that thing and
that progress is the foundational
building block of happiness how do you
feel about yourself
when you're by yourself
i know a lot of people that fear
that quiet
i know a lot of people that don't want
to be alone with themselves
and the reason they don't want to be
alone with themselves
is because they don't
think
they're worthwhile
they're not happy with who they are
that's what adaptation is
about if you're not happy with who you
are
then let's step into the ownership of
that let's remember that's our fault
there's no one else to blame for that
the people that did horrible things to
you are not to blame for that
because if they are there's nothing you
can do
but if you're
the owner of that
in fact don't even worry about the word
blame you're in control that's what this
is about it's about retaining control
it's about knowing that you own your
life and at any time if you want a
different outcome you can make different
decisions you can do different things
you can start a new narrative
and once you begin that new narrative
you realize the power that's in that to
take you where you want to go the
american dream is still alive for
anybody if you're willing
to learn and grow first of all if you're
willing to accept you're not yet the
person you need to be to execute at the
highest level you're willing to
acknowledge your deficits and understand
what skills you need and then go out and
relentlessly acquire those skills that
have utility and then be willing to put
that those skills to the test against
something for me the test is business
it's the test i enjoy it's not the test
everyone enjoys but that's what quest
was largely me asking and answering the
question
am i acquiring the right skills in order
to end metabolic disease yes or no and
if the answer was no i changed as
epictetus said
he is a wise man who does not grieve for
things which he has not
but rejoices for those which he has
and that's gratitude isn't it
it's the very base decision that we all
have to make
are you grateful for the things you have
in your life or are you always wanting
more and trust me i get it
i understand people that strive for more
i understand people that want something
bigger and better but at the same time
if you allow yourself to only think
about what you don't have to only be
striving for something more that that
obsession will begin to overtake you it
will begin to corrode you
but ultimately it's a choice ultimately
at any time right now in this moment you
can stop
and think about what you have you can
put your attention on the things you're
grateful for and watch what it does
watch what it does in that instance the
way that it changes you the way that it
changes your chemistry your feelings in
a moment
can shift from negative and dark
to
beautiful
with nothing else changing around you
nothing but you deciding
that you're going to focus on the things
you're grateful for nothing but deciding
that there are things in your life to be
grateful for and that is a decision no
matter what is happening in your life at
any moment right now in the depths of a
depression in something going on
terribly in your life you can choose
right now
to think about the things you're
grateful for
the breeze
a smile from somebody kind a stranger
who holds open a door for you anything
but it's a choice
and as einstein said there are only two
ways to live your life
one is as though nothing is a miracle
the other
is as though everything is a miracle
and what choice are you making
what are you choosing to focus on right
now
do you let gratitude fill you up or not
and here's the critical part and i want
you to listen to this really well
whatever you decide whether you decide
we live in a world of miracles or
whether you decide we live in a world
devoid of miracles you are choosing one
thing to the exclusion of the other and
when you focus on something that you're
grateful for when you look at those
little moments in your life and choose
to see them as grand miracles even when
it is only a gentle hand on your
shoulder even when it's only a kiss from
somebody who you've kissed a thousand
times before even when it is only
holding the hand of somebody who needed
their hand held even when it's something
that simple
it really is a miracle that it really is
something that can fill you it really is
something that will change your
chemistry bring a connection between two
people allow you to see a grander vista
or even just open a window and look out
at the world and realize that you're
alive that this is all
a miracle that none of this is
guaranteed that every breath you take
could be your last
and in that
you can choose to cherish
what you have in that you can decide to
focus on
that you have a breath to take
and even when it's something that simple
when you train your mind to do that when
you train yourself to decide to see the
beauty in that
that nobody can ever take it away from
you
and no matter where you are
no matter what's going on in your life
you'll be able to rise up and feel the
beauty
that is being alive
so take a minute
at the worst times in your life
and focus on the things you're grateful
for you have to fight to reach your
dream
you have to sacrifice and work hard for
it
that's coming from the man who has come
to define natural talent
but that's what other people put on him
people want to see somebody who's just
naturally talented it's god given they
were graced they were blessed with
something at birth
but what does he say when he's asked
about what it took to become the person
that he is
it took hard work it took sacrifice it
took giving things up it took doubling
down it took pushing himself every day
day after day and that's the thing about
hard work
when you put that kind of unending
blinding effort into something it gets
to the point where you've worked so hard
that it looks like magic that people
would sooner believe that it's dna that
it's gifted that it is god-given than to
believe
that they would have to work that hard
to replicate it but if you can stop
making other people extraordinary as a
way to let yourself off the hook then
you too can become extraordinary all of
us are capable of far more than we think
we're capable of more than the people
who love us the most think we are
capable of more than the people who hate
us the most would have us believe
at the end of the day
it is a very simple question you're
going to have to ask yourself
and answer for yourself
how hard are you willing to work
how much are you willing to sacrifice
but on the other side of that is power
and energy and as kyle rowe jr said if
you're attacking you don't get as tired
as when you're chasing
and that's the key
when you
know
what you want and when you will not be
held back from getting it suddenly you
go on the offensive it's not about
pleasing somebody else it's not about
chasing somebody else becoming them or
even beating them it is about yourself
knowing what you want and attacking it
going after it and not letting anybody
dissuade you it is looking at yourself
and recognizing how you have to improve
to get that good but you've got to
hunger for that goal you've got to
hunger to get across and win you've got
to want that
the way that a man whose head is on fire
wants a pond
and when you get to that stage when
you're able to cultivate something in
yourself like that something that is
refusing to be extinguished something
that will be heard something that will
stand up and be counted
then you're going to have what you need
to get the skills that you need to move
forward to win to attack and in that
attack and having the energy to move
forward relentlessly
you will find that even though you're
working harder than you've ever worked
in your life
you're more energized than you've ever
been in your life
the times where you fatigue
they're not the times you're working the
hardest
the times you fatigue are when you're
being least yourself
you're not being true to who you are and
what you want
so right now
right now
start being honest
about what it is you're willing to
attack
start being honest about who you want to
be what you're willing to become and the
price you're willing to pay to get there
if you give yourself over to that you
will not be able to be stopped there's a
difference between happiness and
fulfillment a bowl of ice cream brings
me happiness
it does not bring me fulfillment
fulfillment is often born of suffering
fulfillment is about doing the things
that are hard in fact the greeks have a
word for it it's called technique
technique means that you acquire a set
of skills that is unique to you the
acquisition of those skills was very
difficult and here's the important part
those skills
serve other people
to me i believe that the very
reason that we're all here
is to see how many skills we can acquire
that have utility
and then put that utility
to the test in service of others
that's gonna be the thing that lights
you on fire you're busting your ass
you're really getting good at something
you are taking action you're moving
forward you're doing the things you need
to learn to do to learn and trigger that
adaptation response that humans have
you're putting yourself under distress
you've identified a goal you're working
your way backwards
to where you are today
and that's the key building yourself
begins with intention
clarity you have to know who you want to
become
you can't just show up in the gym of the
mind and do random stuff anymore then
you can show up in the gym of the body
and do random stuff and think you're
going to end up on the stage
competing for mr olympia
it doesn't work like that
you've got to have this clarity of focus
and the way that i always explain it to
people people come to me all the time
and they're like tom
i want to help people man
and i'm like that is rad that's coming
from such a beautiful place
but telling me that you want to help
somebody is like saying you want to win
a gold medal
in what
the olympics
yes fantastic summer or winter
summer great tennis are swimming
swimming
which event
backstroke the medley because until you
know exactly in what way you are trying
to serve people you don't know what
skills you need to acquire in order to
leave people in awe so that you may
become extraordinary
skills have utility learning how to swim
better makes you a faster swimmer
building certain muscles in your arms
and in your shoulders
all of the different things that go into
getting great at any sport all of those
things must be learned with calculation
they must be practiced and rehearsed
over and over and over you have to push
yourself long past the point of boredom
boredom kills more people in the pursuit
of success than any hater will ever kill
boredom is the great killer of dreams
boredom
because people don't have the focus they
don't have the clarity of what they're
trying to achieve they've not built into
their life built into their life an
intoxication for what they're trying to
accomplish
first of all each and every one of you
needs to avoid what kevin kelly calls
premature optimization then you need to
go out and experience a whole lot of
stuff now premature optimization is
where somebody thinks off the jump oh
this thing i'm kind of interested in
that i'm going to optimize my life for
that thing
the reason this happens is god forbid
you went to a high school where they
already already made you choose like
more or less a major which they do in
the uk and i think it's problematic and
some schools do here in the us
then certainly by the time you get to
college everyone is forcing you they
want you to pick a major
then when you get out you've got to get
a job and you want to get a job that
makes sense with the major that you just
got she took on all this debt and you
spent all this time and so that's
premature optimization you literally
made a decision when you were 18 maybe
17 terrifying and now the whole rest of
your life is an echo of that random
decision you made before your brain was
finished developing think about that for
a second your brain doesn't stop
developing until you're 25. so at 18
and that's late honestly most people are
thinking about it at 17 or even 16
you're making a decision you're
prematurely optimizing you haven't
experienced enough stuff you don't know
what really lights that initial spark of
interest and so you go down this path
you're it you're at 25 you're having a
quarter life crisis because you don't
love what you do it's a mess so
my advice
is to go experience a whole lot of
things now whether that's taking a gap
year which i would never have done
so trust me when i say that's not your
only option but you need to be
experiencing a lot of stuff trying a lot
of things taking a lot of classes
watching videos tutorials reading
learning like figuring out what it is
you go whoa i really like that thing
it's not a passion it's not going to
spark off like that it's just experience
you find something ah it piques your
curiosity you're more interested in that
than the next thing okay now we're going
to engage with it this is step two
engagement is different than just going
and experiencing so that's sort of a a
very non-committal dilettante sort of
way of involving yourself with something
just experiencing it the next is i
really like this and i'm gonna go hard
on it so if i took a dance class now i'm
gonna sign up for a year's worth of
dance classes or something i'm gonna
start going and i'm really gonna see if
i like this and in that engagement
process where you're starting to read
about it you're talking to other people
about it you're going to find out if the
more you get into it the more you're
like whoa this went from an interest to
like a real fascination fascination is
that next
gate if it turns into a fascination and
you're like whoa the more i learn about
this more i want to learn and the more
that i get just excited about this the
more energy it gives me okay that's a
good chance then that that thing can
become a passion now we're going to go
through the process of actually gaining
mastery now i think passion is like love
meaning it needs to be a reciprocal
thing so as you go down the process of
gaining mastery those skills need to
then be useful in the real world and the
echo that you get back from the real
world that those skills are valuable to
other people the more you're gonna be
like whoa i feel good about myself so
now you had something that was
interesting it turned into a fascination
the more you engaged with it and now as
you gain skills you're actually able to
serve other people who then give you
that positive reinforcement where you're
like whoa not only am i getting good at
this like that getting good has real
world utility and it impacts other
people and then they echo that back and
that makes me feel really good about
myself so i enjoy it in and of itself
and i enjoy that
element of technique where as a social
species i am helping other parts of my
tribe and that feels really good and
it's something that other people value
that is the passion now fanning the
flames is a slightly different thing to
the side of that which is in that
process which i think it starts pretty
early probably starts back at the
interest phase as you get interested in
something you're going to start doing
things like what i'm doing
right
now
two seconds before the camera started
rolling i was not talking like this i
did not have this energy level
i wasn't using my hands as much or my
face is much oddly enough
but embodying something is absolutely
critical so a big part of gaining a
passion is telling other people what
you're up to allowing yourself to embody
the excitement telling yourself and
other people that you're excited about
it and actually embodying that
excitement embodying that passion which
then your brain goes whoa we're getting
really excited about this you know we're
our volume is getting higher we're
getting more energetic we're moving more
all of that stuff forces the brain to
say this must actually be really
important and when you start doing that
then you're beginning to hardwire your
brain for that and you're beginning to
associate the emotion with that thing
that you're doing it is something that
you can very much do
as long as based on something real i
find that this is pretty ineffective if
there isn't that real core level of
interest but if you have that real core
level of interest then all of a sudden
everything that you do just magnifies
that over and over and over yes
you might embarrass yourself you might
end up doing a face plant you might end
up wishing that you hadn't even started
but if it's important enough
even in that moment
you've got to get back up and ask
yourself honestly
where did i fail what was the skill that
i didn't have that was required of this
task and once you stop beating yourself
up once you stop turning inward with a
judgment of i'm not good enough and you
start turning inward with the judgment
of i don't have good enough skills yet
then you can do something because you
know it's only a matter of time effort
and focus between who you are today and
who you need to become to actually do
that thing so don't worry about whether
or not you're going to fail because the
only promise that i can make you is that
you will fail
and as long as the only promise that
you're willing to make yourself is that
you won't stop
ultimately you will get to the top of
the mount there's a gap between who you
are today
and who you will need to become
in order to execute against your why
that thing in you that's burning that
you really care about enough to get
across the finish line that you care
about enough to keep doing even when
it's making your hands cramp clothes
that you care about enough even when
you've got to come in and work between
rival gang members it's the thing that
you care about enough that you really
will work so hard
that the rival gang members fall in line
behind you because you're leading by
example
thank you
and that became my mission every day
i'm going to show up and outwork
everybody
i'm going to be the first one here i'm
going to be the last one to leave and
most importantly guys
i really hope you were listening to
robert gildini whose books i have read
and all but memorized
the key is
you want to
connect with them you want them to fall
in love with you you want them to be
inspired you want them to feel better
about themselves when they're around you
than when they're not
and if you can pull that off they will
go to war for you think about it
if somebody is going to come after you
and they want to hurt your feelings
there's one thing every time they will
reach for
that is something that is true
when people try to hurt you they go for
the most real thing and they jab you
right in your heart
because they know it's gonna hurt
because it's real man
and that's mean for sure and it hurts
for sure
but if you think of it like this when
somebody's throwing a rock at you with
the intention of hurting you you can put
your defenses up
you will deflect that rock never to be
seen again
or
you can lower your defenses let it hit
you in the face
knowing that it will hurt
but also knowing now at your feet is not
a rock it's a lump of gold because
they've given you an insight into where
you are weak
now once you know where you are weak
you can begin to build yourself
and that is my thesis on life
you get to build yourself in any
direction you want in any way to become
anything you want there will be an
extraordinary price to pay
but you can go in any direction i don't
go oh that's interesting brightline i go
okay that's interesting i want to
explore that more what would that look
like how would that serve me what would
it really feel like for me
how's it playing out in my life does it
actually have real world implications
and this isn't all something that i sit
down in one quick session like that's
what i'm thinking about i may think
about it for
weeks a month more six months who knows
and it depends on what kind of impact
that it's gonna have in my life so i
don't you don't lead with bright lines
to create a habit let's be really clear
about that so habits are something
different getting in routines and habits
is a place to start and then if you find
like i have a morning routine i have
habits that i do every morning but they
they are things that i'm very flexible
on that creates a lot of
mobility in my life if i wake up late or
something like that then i'll just shave
this out or the other bright lines like
i
if i have a bright line i don't [ __ ]
with my bright lines i do my bright
lines so that's the whole point of a
bright line they are absolutely
non-negotiable so
be very careful about what you put
bright lines around make sure it is
something that's leading you towards
your goal
and i think better to make it a habit
and a routine first and see if it
actually has an advantage if it's
something that's important and if it's
something that you struggle with and
think that it's really really important
and you need that bright line and in the
beginning
when all we could do because we didn't
know production we just had to throw
human capital at it and i needed people
there not kidding
at 2 a.m on a friday night
i had a bunch of
ex-convicts
in their early 20s with the tattoos on
the face the teardrop and all that
grinding it out to make protein bars
because i gave them hope
because i showed them
that it doesn't matter who they are
today
it only matters who they're trying to
become
and the price that they're willing to
pay to get there
and so when you guys
walk out of here
that's what you've got to ask this whole
theme of pivoting this whole theme of
keeping your center
is about knowing what you want
and believing you can make it a reality
but the only way to make it a reality is
to put in the work
you've got to put in the work the change
is hard the change is difficult the
change will demand everything of you
but man if inside you really believe in
what you're doing you really see how you
can get to that goal that you want if
you really see how you can serve other
people doing what you do with this skill
set that you've worked your ass off to
acquire
then you can actually make change in
people's lives and that's what motivates
me getting the skills has real world
implications it took me from scrounging
in my couch cushions to find enough
change to put gas in my car to building
a billion dollar business
it is absolutely limitless what you can
accomplish
now think about that if that's really
true if what i just said is true that
human potential is limitless
then how you spend your time becomes a
spiritual consideration now i don't
think that we're born blank slates
but we are so close to that
to worry about where your limits are
is to miss how much you can improve
so focus on how much you can improve
there's an amazing quote by alexander
solzhenitsyn the author of the goulet
archipelago
and what he said was
the line between good and evil runs
through every human heart
to me it's not about good and evil to me
it's about malleability
that's a statement of how
shapeable we are now here's the
terrifying thing about how we get shaped
it happens when you're young
you get all these things that come to
you that seem to be simply true
i believed
that the human mind couldn't change i
believed that it was fixed i believed
that my talent and intelligence were
just what they were
it all seemed true
it wasn't like i knew it to be a lie it
wasn't even like i knew that i had a
choice to think of it a different way
and one of my favorite quotes of all
time is from albert einstein and he said
the most important decision any human
being has to make
is whether they live in a friendly or a
hostile universe
decision the most important decision
anyone has to make because neither of
those two states is empirically true but
either will immediately appear true once
you decide to believe it
so once you decide to believe yo
the world is working for me this is
happening for me it's not happening to
me i know this room has heard that
statement
once you believe that you start looking
for the ways in which that was powerful
how was the worst thing that ever
happened to me actually secretly the
best thing that's ever happened to me
and so suddenly i started saying how is
this shame of sitting in bed
how is this the best thing that's ever
happened to me
how is this solieri type awareness of
just how dumb i really am how is that
powerful and the thing that winds me up
when i say that when i talk about i
started from not being that bright
nobody thought i was gonna win my own
mother thought i was gonna fail my
father-in-law did not want me to marry
his daughter they think that i'm just
being humble or that even i
misidentified myself but the reality is
that's how shapeable a human being is
and i had made decisions i had chosen to
believe things i had chosen to value
myself for things i had built myself
around my self-esteem around things that
were not moving me forward
and so i began to change my belief
system i began to change the things that
i value
and think about values think about how
much they shape your life depending on
where you grow up
you could become
one of the members of the tribe on north
sentinel island who killed that
missionary who rolled up on their
beaches they just started hitting that
fool with spears and arrows it killed
him
you could be that you could be a warrior
of sparta
you could be a nazi guard
depending on the time and the place you
grew up in you could be a manhattan
socialite you could be a party girl
you could be
one of any countless identities that we
see in the world
not because you were born to be that
thing
if we were born to be something then we
would still see some percentage of
spartan warriors being born today
we would see north sentinelese born in
omaha nebraska
but we don't because each of these
places carries with it a value system a
belief system things that are unique to
that group that you grow up in what your
parents tell you about your family about
you what it means to be you what you
learn in schools what you see in the
media all of that stuff is shaping how
you view yourself and how you view the
world but it's happening insidious
insidiously because it is so invisible
people don't realize that they are
choices
now once you reframe all of this these
are things that i'm choosing to believe
and once you realize you can choose to
believe something new and thusly get a
different result everything changes now
i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that it's time for the question of the
day i want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video and
your plan of action for the next week
when you just get inspired you watch a
video you get motivated amazing the
science says you have a 35 chance of
actually doing something actually
following through that believe nation is
not enough that is not you not now not
anymore not today but when you get
inspired and then you create a specific
plan of action for what you're going to
do that number jumps to 91 chance of you
following through and when you commit
publicly to others like leaving a
comment in this video it jumps to 95
so the question of the day is your
single biggest takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week put it down in the comments below
and maybe next week i'll profile you
you're big on learning a lot of skill
sets right what would you say has the
highest what skill set has the highest
upside highest return
the
the baseline thing people have to have
is
emotional resilience so you have to and
this to me is a skill you have to learn
how to emotionally recalibrate so when i
was the kid in the server room and there
was a whole bunch of people farther
ahead in their entrepreneurial journey
than i and they all heard the same
message about you can be a partner and
none of them did anything with it i
started asking why aren't they doing
anything with it
and i realized the answer was i could
self-soothe faster than they could and
so yeah it hurt when i was told i was an
idiot that really sucked
especially hearing it from someone you
really respect but
i decided to not spin out of control not
waste three days being hurt by it but
instead to recenter and just ask are
they right
because if they're right there's
something to learn here and if they're
not right just move on and if they are
right learn the lesson and so i just
slowly started collecting it and the
lessons and the image i started thinking
was whenever somebody throws an insult
at you you have two options you can let
it hit you in the head or you can raise
your defenses and defect it and your
defenses are the psychological immune
system they're real i'm not making that
up so
all of us have this thing that comes to
our aid when somebody says something
that hurts you then you're like oh well
they're mean anyway they're a jerk
they're a bully whatever i don't have to
take them seriously and so that makes
you feel better and you believe maybe
that they're being cosmically punished
in some way being a bully is its own
punishment and all that so and ah like
that allows you to relax and they've
done studies that show people with the
highest level of self-delusion are the
happiest so there really is something to
it but the people at the highest level
self-delusion are usually not the ones
that go the farthest because they
don't stop to recognize where they
really are to own the pain of that so i
thought okay instead of raising my
defenses i'm going to lower my defenses
i'm going to let that rock hit me in the
head because at my feet now is actually
a nugget of gold and i'm going to pick
up that nugget of gold and form the
lesson that the person is throwing at me
and here's the thing to realize when
people really come at you they're really
trying to hurt you they have sinister
intent they're going to come at you with
something that's true
nobody comes at you with the stuff
that's not real they're going to hit you
with like the thing that you're the most
secure about in the world
so even the people with the the gravest
of intent are the ones that are giving
you the most powerful gift because you
may be blind to it or maybe you didn't
want to acknowledge it but if you can
let it hit you as much as it hurts then
bend down pick it up and learn from it
now you can do something i
applied to usc but didn't realize you
had to apply to usc film school
separately so i get into usc but i have
terrible sat scores i took a 990 or i
took it twice and i got a 990 combined
score it's terrible they do it
differently now so people don't realize
just how bad that's going that sucks
actually that was atrocious
and so
when i looked at the film school it
required a 1300. and so i was like whoa
how am i supposed to get in i go see the
school counselor at usc and they say
listen tom
stop because i was taking film classes
the general education classes they said
immediately stop taking those classes
you are not going to get into film
school not words like that those words
they said statistically speaking you're
more likely to get into harvard law than
you are to get into usc film school the
number of people that apply is ungodly
the number of slots are tiny you're not
going to get in you're going to end up
spending a fifth year here because you
will have wasted your time
and i said okay
i'm going to get in thank you very much
the stubbornness in me so if you say i
can't i'm going to
and i said there's got to be a way to
figure this out and i found out that one
of the teachers that was on the
admissions committee would let you join
him for lunch
so i joined him for lunch and as much as
i can't believe this no one else did it
was just me and so i'm sitting down with
him and i'm like all right look dude
here's the situation
i want to get into film school but i got
a 990 of my sets he was like tom what
does sat stand for and i said um
scholastic aptitude test he's like
that's correct it's meant to tell me how
well you're going to do in college so
there are two admissions periods one as
you're coming into college in which case
i care deeply about your sats and then
the other is as an incoming junior he
said you've already missed the freshman
window so your sats don't matter anymore
what i want to see is how good of grades
can you get because that tells me how
well you're actually doing in college he
said i don't care if you're already a
good filmmaker we want to make you a
good filmmaker i just need to know you
know how to learn so he said get good
grades so i locked myself in my dorm for
the next two years i didn't drink i
didn't party i didn't date i didn't do
anything but study and i studied like a
beast and at the end of those two years
i either had a four point or like a
three nine five something crazy and so i
got into film school so now i'm like i'm
i told you i was gonna get in i got in
and i did it in a clever way i went and
asked the guy what i had to do he told
me i did it for two years i was crazy
disciplined and it worked man and i'm
here
there are three production classes that
you have you've got a 290 a 310 and you
crew of 480 which is a senior thesis
film so i do my 290s they're pretty good
i start getting attention from my
filmmaking so in 290 people like wow
this kid he's kind of one to watch
because my two my 290s were so good for
310 you have to partner with somebody
now you have to either be a director or
cinematographer now needless to say
everybody wants to be a director
but then if you're not going to be a
director or sorry if you're going to be
a director you want to get the best
cinematographer and so what ends up
happening is the people that can't get a
cinematographer end up being
cinematographers so a lot of times like
people sort of make do i wanted to be a
director and one of the other best
directors wanted to be a cinematographer
so now everybody wanted him as their
cinematographer and he chose me
so now i've been one to watch in 290 i
get the ideal partner for 310 and we
kill how did you get that guy
um he thought i was talented fun to be
around and that i was one to watch and
so in terms of i would be a good person
to partner with in order to get a good
480. so partners with me and we kill it
and we don't make the classic mistake
that most uh student filmmakers make
which is to tell a feature length film
as a you know silent film so we told a
very short moment in time as a silent
black and white film where you wouldn't
expect people to talk anyway so it
didn't feel like a silent film so people
love it does very well
we both get top level crewing positions
on a 480 we both crush that and both of
us actually end up getting selected only
four people get chosen for uh 480 and we
both got selected to direct at 480. so
now i go from you're never getting into
film school kid
you're more likely to get into harvard
law than usc film to being one of only
four people to not only get in but
direct a senior thesis film
so right i'm killing it with tom what
are you talking about you failed at film
school baby you did everything you were
one to watch and i was like man i'm
making it i'm gonna graduate i'm gonna
get my three picture deal this is gonna
be amazing i'm naturally talented i knew
it everything has proven to me that i
have natural talent as a filmmaker fixed
mindset all day but who cares baby
because i got the talent then i go into
the 480 as a director and i [ __ ] up and
i crash and burn so spectacularly that
people are taking snippets of my film
and cutting them into what we would now
call memes but at the time was just like
mean to be funny and they would like
screen it in front of the class people
would be pissing their pants with
laughter because it was so bad
and i was having like basically an
emotional breakdown and i call my mom
from the middle of uh the school i'm
laying on the ground on a pay phone and
i'm like my life is over
and i'm going to graduate now from film
school with no senior thesis that i can
show anybody
and this is a point filmmaking there's
no like digital filmmaking no one's ever
made a film on digital before that
doesn't exist if you want to shoot a
film minimum for a no budget films a
hundred thousand dollars that might as
well be 100 million dollars so i
graduate i steal my master by the way
which i still have because it is that
bad i know when people hear this story
they just think i'm being humble i'm
telling you just put it on youtube
over my
i've told this story many times i don't
i think my wife has seen it but only
once so yeah over my dead body that
thing will never be seen although i i
have to admit like at some point maybe
it'd be cool to show one once i have
something that i'm that i've done that
i'm proud of i might show it uh but you
could make that part when you give when
you give uh presentations
to show a clip of it yeah you're
absolutely right
anyway no not at all so
i steal the master because it's that bad
and i never want people to see it
and i graduate and now i feel lost and
i'm like i'm never gonna break in my
life is like i had one shot i actually
made it and
i totally messed it up and so it's over
i'm never going to be a filmmaker and
that was my identity i was a filmmaker
and so now that was gone and i was like
wow i don't know what to do and so i was
sliding towards depression i would lay
on my the floor of my unfurnished
apartment because i couldn't afford to
furnish it and i remember the feeling of
the vinyl carpet smashing into my face
because i would just lay there for an
hour two hours at a time
and i was like yep my life is over i
don't know what to do i'm sliding
towards depression and thankfully i
started reading about the brain to avoid
sliding towards depression so now there
are two ways to look at my film career
one is dude
against all odds
you became through hard work and
discipline not because anything was
given to you people told you you would
never do it and you worked and worked
and worked and you got it and you did it
and you were one of the four people
selected to do a 480 and the amount even
though your 40 wasn't good the amount
that you learned from that 40
transformed you not just as a filmmaker
as a human being and became one of the
most transformative revolutionary things
that set you up that's real that story
is there and what you just heard
the other story is
you got arrogant
you got cocky you believed you were the
next john wu that you could roll up on
set that you were naturally gifted you
didn't have to work so you hardly broke
your script at all you like i wrote the
script in like an hour before having to
turn it in to be considered i never
touched it again until the first day of
shooting didn't storyboard nothing just
rolled up and thought i'll know where to
put the camera it'll all just feel
instinctive and
intuitive and so i went and nothing was
working it was all garbage my crew
didn't believe in me the film was
falling apart teachers tried to save me
but couldn't get through to me because i
was so convinced i know what i'm doing
and it just turned into a pile of
garbage because i have no talent now
both of those scenarios are true it is
true that at that time i did not have
talent
now it doesn't mean i couldn't develop
skill but i didn't have talent so
which do you which story do you repeat
to yourself for the first probably two
years after i graduated i repeated the
i'm not talented story then i began
reading about the brain and realized oh
i just haven't developed skills yet and
so then i began to change the story and
to focus on
the discipline and all the things that
i'd learned and all that but both are
true and so what i tell people is
because you're more likely to believe
something negative don't even worry
about what's true worry about what
empowers you when it comes to just
yourself i'm not talking about you know
a
fake news or you know a post-truth world
i'm just saying for yourself there's
both of those narratives are based on
facts so the truth of one or the other
doesn't matter one is empowering and one
is disempowering act in accordance with
the one that's empowering going out and
doing the hard things to see how much of
your potential you can actuate pursuing
greatness in a very specific direction
is i believe the only thing that will
make people happy so when i look at
depression anxiety all on the rise all
rampant people feeling lost not knowing
what they want to do where they want to
be the answer is
decide you're going to be extraordinary
at something because it gives you more
energy than it takes and there's all
process not going to go into it now but
get that thing in your life and then go
after it with everything you have with
total disregard for balance
that you pour yourself into it in a way
you give yourself over to it
and i think we have one more bifurcation
you've got the family which provides a
similar sense of deep fulfillment and i
think that's a perfectly valid choice
and if you don't hear the incongruous
nature with what i'm saying i'm not
saying it very well
but those are the two paths that i see
humans go on people that are parents
they really the kid was born changed my
life perspective totally done right like
you know the the talk and how it feels
and then on this side you've got an
equal lack of balance all in totally
committed do or die i would give myself
over to this thing that i'm building
right and that's where i'm at i've
chosen not to have kids it's not the
path i'm on but i've given myself over
in a similar way and i get a similar
sense of deep fulfillment what set me
free to deal with my insecurities was
recognizing that i could get better and
the only thing that i think makes people
really run from their insecurities is
when it's something they don't think
they can do anything about which is why
looks is far more terrifying than a lot
of other things especially for women so
having a growth mindset allowed me to
address
the things that i felt that i could
change which are
i won't say the sum total of my
insecurities but are the certainly the
vast majority of my insecurities and
that is very freeing and i would say
that's where most people need to start
listen and listen well because no truer
words are ever going to be spoken
you can do anything you want without
limitation whatever it is that you
decide you want to make come true in
your life you can
do that it is going to take an inhuman
amount of work you're going to have to
be prepared to break yourself in half
you're going to have to learn more than
anyone has ever learned you're going to
have to push yourself harder than anyone
has ever asked you to push yourself
before you're going to go way beyond
your breaking point you're going to run
until you vomit you're going to study
until you fall asleep you're going to
push and push and push and then you're
going to push
more and when you hit the limit you're
going to push again beyond that you're
going to force yourself into an
adaptation response and why
because as malcolm x said
the future belongs to those who prepare
for it today
so if you don't put the work in today
if you don't do
the unending back breaking work of
developing yourself into something
greater the world is going to pass you
by the people that are going to own it
are going to be the ones that did that
work and the one promise that i can make
you right now is that somebody
somebody out there is out working
somebody right now
is doing the things that i'm saying
somebody right now
is doing the work of failing and getting
up and getting better and pushing
themselves and triggering that glorious
adaptation response that makes humans
the apex predator someone right now
they're putting in that work
and if you don't
the future is going to belong to them
and as martin luther king jr said
if you can't fly then run
if you can't run then walk if you can't
walk then crawl but whatever you do
you have to keep moving forward
it's not okay to make excuses it's not
gonna slow people down it's not okay to
ask the world to stop so that you can
step out front it's not okay to expect
little of yourself and
demand great rewards the only thing
that's okay is to be in line with the
way that the world really works and if
you want to be great you've got to
become capable of greatness you've got
to develop your skill set you've got to
take what you have now and if that's
crawling then crawl but you drag
yourself ever forward to a vision of
yourself that is so clear and so
specific that nothing could knock you
off your path because you my friend know
exactly where you're going you're
willing to pay whatever price it takes
to get there and no matter what anybody
says no matter how many hecklers come
for you no matter how many people try to
throw dirt on you try to stop them try
to knock you down no matter how many
people come for you at night while you
sleep you will rise and you will keep
pushing forward and you will get better
every day and no matter how many times
people chop at you knock you down knock
you off the path you will get back on
you will crawl till you can walk you
will walk till you run and then you will
run until you fly and that my friends is
the only path forward so if you want a
future that makes you happy if you want
a world that you're excited about get
your ass out there and earn it if you
want more top 10 videos they're not on
this channel anymore i have a dedicated
channel just for it go check it out the
link is right there next to me continue
to believe and i'll see you there